on Tuesday some dude named Christian de
Lyon wrote a column for the New York
Post that became the internet outrage -
sure the column titled why I won't date
hot women anymore made the case that
outrageously beautiful women are shallow
and vapid and that the same is true for
men and also implied that non
supermodels who are merely beautiful are
better pick the column begins with the
story of Dan rock kind of private equity
douchebags as quote when it came to
dating in New York is a 30-something
executive in private equity Dan rockin
had no problem snagging the mass it ease
most beautiful women I could have had
anyone I wanted says rockin now forty in
an Upper West Sider with a muscular
build and a full head of hair by the way
these kind of weird-looking cuz I met
some really nice people but
realistically I went for the hottest
girl you could find
he spent the better part of his 30s
going on up to three dates a week
courting twenty-something blonde models
but eventually realized that dating the
prettiest young things had its drawbacks
he found them flighty
selfish and vapid beautiful women who
get a fair amount of attention get full
of themselves he says eventually I was
dreading getting dinner with them
because they couldn't carry a
conversation so how did Raj ken's who
clearly prioritize physical beauty /
intelligence kindness and decency
solvable problem he stopped dating
supermodels quote looking to avoid such
a fate roschin started dating a woman
who isn't a bikini model Carly spindle
in January 2015 the two are now happily
engaged the two met after spindell's
mother matchmaker janice spindle scouted
rock into the gym I gave him my card and
I said I have the perfect girl for him
recalls janice founder of serious
matchmaking based in midtown successful
men who are in shape have the pickings
when it comes to dating
but eventually they want a woman of
substance there are a few problems here
first off spindle is extremely
good-looking perhaps the problem here
isn't level of beauty but the fact that
women who generally go into the Keeney
modeling may not on average have the
same intellectual aspirations as women
who become doctors in other words the
supposed brains Beauty disconnect may
not actually be a brains Beauty
disconnect at all rather a bikini model
brains disconnect people who spend their
entire lives getting ready to get mostly
naked on a beach somewhere may not be
people who are concerned with reading up
to up on the latest economic
developments in the loss for journal but
according to go lion nobody should say
beautiful people at all if they want a
stable relationship quote according to
new research Raj chicken's idea about
sexy bikini babes are correct a
multi-part study from Harvard University
University of Laverne and Santa Clara
University researchers found that
beautiful people are more likely to be
involved in unstable relationships in
one part the researchers looked at the
top 20
verses on IMDB and found that they tend
to have rocky marriages and another
women were asked to judge the
attractiveness of 238 men based on their
high school yearbook photos from 30
years ago the men who are judged to be
the best looking had higher rates of
divorce this is ridiculous
both of these studies are flawed maybe
the problem with actresses isn't that
they're beautiful it's that they are
actresses and maybe the good-looking
guys in high school were treated like
gods and just turned into rock and the
answer to shallowness isn't more
shallowness actually the reaction about
dating experiences with beautiful people
isn't dating non beautiful people
necessarily it's to hold physical beauty
as one portion of the dating calculus
but not the whole equation
my wife is gorgeous but she's
particularly gorgeous to me because
she's a beautiful person not just
because she has a beautiful body she has
terrific values a great sense of humor
ambition and drive she's brilliant and
fun a terrific mother and a profoundly
good human being I was looking
specifically for all of those things
when I was dating we've been married for
nearly a decade and when we're both old
and wrinkly I'll still be in love with
her she'll still be beautiful to me even
when are the youth fades now to be fair
roschin seems have discovered that he
now recognizes that yes Beauty has a
large physical component but there's
beauty and personality brains and values
that's why people stay married even
after they get old and wrinkly rather
than upgrading for the newer model
here's roschin quote she is a softer
Beauty someone you can take home and
cuddle with and she's very elegant Raj
Caen says and she's 5 foot 2 so she
can't be a runway model but I think
she's really beautiful and it's prettier
than anyone I've dated
sadly Raj can douchiness isn't going
away anytime soon he says there's
something to be said about sowing your
Wild Oats and getting them out of your
system so suraj chickens will marry
Carly in June at a Tuscan romantic
ceremony at the Wolfert estate vineyard
in the Hamptons but he doesn't regret
his past you don't want to be the first
to leave the party but you don't want to
leave the party too late either he says
Carly came at exactly the right time in
other words use beautiful the cello
women then dump them by the side of the
road later when you're getting older and
ready to settle down in both the looks
and character Department Raj Kent is
obviously no catch
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
all righty so I don't know why people
are talking to me from behind the camera
right is this the under happened but
there are some women in the office who
are obviously interested in this topic
so we'll have to have that discussion
after the show not right now guys come
on okay so before we get into the news
of the day and there's lots of news
Trump is flipping on a bunch of issues
and will talk about whether that is good
or bad and what exactly that reflects
about Trump is this the new presidency
or is this just more ideological
incoherence we'll talk about all of that
we also talked about the Sean Spicer
thing because everybody's going nuts
because Sean Spicer said something
really dumb about the Holocaust
yesterday let me just say very briefly
Barack Obama helped forward an actual
Holocaust in both Syria and then also in
Iran and anti Jewish version wants to
murder every Jew on the planet and he
helps give them nuclear weapons the
media were complicit in that but they're
really pissed because Sean Spicer said
something really dumb about the
Holocaust but we'll talk about all that
in just a minute first I want to say
thank you to our advertisers are over at
link so if you are one of the people who
read that column about the the dude who
doesn't want to date beautiful women
anymore and it just makes you want to
drink then try winked calm if you if you
are going over to somebody's house for
dinner and you don't know anything about
line if you're like me and wine you just
think is fermented grape juice and you
leave some kind of in the fridge and
that turns into wine and then you bring
it over to a friend's house and they say
what in the world are you doing then you
need to go over to try wink calm winc
calm slash men because they will tell
you what kind of line is good what a
pairs with and the way that this works
if you go on their website and you take
a survey so what tastes you like what
takes you like together and then they
recommend a bottle of wine for you the
bottles of wine are really affordable at
ten bucks apiece and they will give you
$20 off plus complimentary shipping at
try wink calm slash pen folks around the
office have tried the wine apparently
they got into the line stash this
morning which is why they're talking to
me during the commercials but in any
case try wink comm slash Ben is the
place to go the line is apparently
really really good and again they will
help you pick the best bottle of wine if
you don't know anything about wine like
me then this is the best place to find
out what they'll tell you what wine you
need to bring to you don't look like a
doofus
Emeline is really really good and
affordable again fry wink calm winc calm
slash spend $20 off plus
complimentary shipping okay
a lot going on in the last two days
apparently I leave for two days and
Donald Trump turns into george w bush
which is weird so he's flipped on an
inordinate number of issues in the last
two days yesterday he flipped on about
six of them and we're going to go
through some of the issues upon which he
flips now some of these flips are good
and so the question we have to ask is is
this trump maturing in office is this
reality slapping trump in the face and
saying you know a lot of your campaign
rhetoric was really nonsensical and now
you're going to have to buckle down
because the reality is that the russians
are in a various force in the world and
the realities the north korea's a
dangerous place and that not every
problem is a simple problem that a
businessman can solve just by wishing it
so is it that is trump actually becoming
more mature or is he just responding to
opinion polls is he just responding to
event is he just trusting Ivanka and
Jared and are we going to get kind of an
incoherent presidency that bounces from
issue to issue and we don't know the
answer to that yet but let's look at
some of the flips because some of them
are actually quite good and I'm pleased
with them as a conservative so for
example yesterday here is what Trump
said about NATO I said it was obsolete
it's no longer obsolete it's my hope
that NATO will take on an increased role
in supporting our Iraqi partners in
their battle against Isis okay and just
to remind you throughout the entire
campaign throughout the entire campaign
he said NATO is obsolete the NATO
basically was done here's what he had to
say during the campaign
justic NATO is obsolete it was 67 years
or it's over 60 years old
okay so NATO is obsolete okay NATO was
not obsolete it's not true now people
are in the Trump administration are
trying to play this like Trump changed
NATO and therefore it's not obsolete
absolutely nonsense
the only NATO action in the last 20
years was in invitation after 9/11 on
behalf of the United States for NATO
forces to go into Afghanistan so the
idea that was obsolete and was not
directed at terror is obviously not true
good for Trump for at least
acknowledging that that's that's a good
shift in position it does demonstrate
that those of us who were criticizing
Trump during the campaign for saying the
sort of stupidity and saying that it
encouraged Vladimir Putin's
aggressiveness that Trump is now
beginning to recognize the truth of that
or at least he's going to flip on that
so that's a good flip okay here's
another good flip yesterday Trump said
that China is not a currency manipulate
okay now China is not a currency
manipulator they stopped several years
ago manipulating their currency and as
I've said many times even with China
inflates their currency that doesn't
actually do anything overall for the
American economy this is why the Vimal
Republic didn't just inflate itself into
prosperity this is why Venezuela didn't
inflate itself into prosperity
there's my Zimbabwe hasn't been able to
inflate itself into prosperity there's
this weird idea in international trade
that if we inflate our currency that
somehow we're going to be benefiting
ourselves because suddenly our products
become cheaper on the international
market right if we inflate our currency
then the the British Pound is worth more
American dollars and they can buy more
American products and therefore it helps
our export industry the problem is that
you inflate our currency you also make
our savings worthless and you make all
the products that we want to buy more
expensive so you actually don't help
your economy overall when you inflate
your currency this is why a strong
dollar is generally weaker and it is
generally better than a weak dollar so
Trump had said throughout the entire
campaign that China was stealing our job
by inflating currency not true and now
yesterday he came out and he said well
not anymore if you recall his website
actually said during the campaign quote
we must stand up to China's blackmail
and reject corporate America's
manipulation of our politician the US
Treasurys designation of China as a
currency manipulator well force signing
to the negotiating table and open the
door to a fair and far better trading
relationship and just a month ago a
couple months ago
he said did China ask us if it was okay
to devalue our currency devalued their
currency making it hard for our
companies to compete yesterday in a Wall
Street Journal interview he said he was
reversing his position because China has
not manipulated their currency for
months and pushing me issue could hurt
us China relations he said I think our
dollar is getting too strong and
partially that's my fault because people
have confidence in me basically I'm too
awesome okay the reality is the dollar
is strong right now because a lot of
other countries are having economic
trouble and America's a good investment
and that's not just about Trump the
dollar has been strong on the
international market for years or it's
not just Trump but good that Trump flips
on this because it's going to been real
awkward for him to say China's currency
manipulator when they have been
manipulating for quite a while
okay other flips that Trump is engaged
in so here's a flashback about Saddam
Hussein if you recall Trump didn't care
five minutes ago when evil Middle
Eastern dictators gasp their own people
here's what Trump said about it suddenly
start fighting again
then Saddam Hussein throws a little gas
everyone goes crazy oh excuse a gas to
go back forth it's the same okay so it's
not a big deal and I'm throw a little
gas and here's Donald Trump I'm Bashar
Assad yesterday with regard to Bashar
Assad using gas on his own people there
can't be a worse sight and it shouldn't
be allowed
that's a butcher that's a butcher so I
felt we had to do something about it I
have absolutely no doubt we did the
right thing okay so again it's good the
Trump is now recognizing the truth that
it is bad for dictators to use gas on
their own people and the the sort of the
sort of casual way in which he was
saying that doesn't matter if he gas her
on people was really silly to begin with
and people bought into that and this is
what I hate about sort of latter
politics are done is that he campaigns
on the basis of a bunch of silly things
and he eventually reverses because as
president he realizes that they're silly
here's another one a month ago on Bill
O'Reilly program he said about Vladimir
Putin that Vladimir Putin in that bad
that Russia is not really that big a
problem the US has a lot of killers
remember this he said this on Bill
O'Reilly program I do respect him to me
why well I respect a lot of people but
that doesn't mean I'm going to get along
with them Putin's a killer a lot of
killers get a lot of killers well you
think our country's so innocent do you
think our country's so innocent I don't
know of any government leaders that are
killers and you know take a look at what
we've done - we've made a lot of
mistakes I've been against the war in
Iraq from the P&A mistakes are different
a lot of mistakes okay but a lot of
people were killed okay and then here is
Donald Trump again yesterday with regard
to Russia relations it would be
wonderful as we were discussing just a
little while ago if NATO and our country
could get along with Russia right now
we're not getting along with Russia at
all we may be at an all-time low in
terms of relationship with Russia this
is built for a long period of time but
we're going to see what happens and
Putin is the leader of Russia Russia is
a strong country we're a very very
strong country we're going to see how
that all were
so and then trump tweeted this morning
that Russia and US relations would work
themselves out because everybody would
get together and realize what's in their
best interest again that's a little bit
of wishful thinking on the part of Trump
are all these things a evidence that
Trump is growing into the job or just
evidence that he's responding to events
based on the information that's being
given to him and could he be flipped on
these things another example of Trump
flipping yesterday your call during the
election cycle he kept saying that he
wanted to be unpredictable
he didn't want to tell people in advance
of military operations that were going
to be taking place and then of course he
told the Russians in advance that we're
going to be firing cruise missiles at
this at this base he should you should
have told the Russians that we don't
want to escalate into a hot war based on
us not telling the Russians what's going
on but here is Trump back during the
campaign saying he wants to be
unpredictable well I'm going to do
what's right I want to be unpredictable
I'm not going to tell you right now what
I'm going to do right he kept saying
that about foreign policy and then
yesterday he was asked about what's he
going to do in Syria and then he just
spills out his plan on what he's going
to do in Syria we're not going into
Syria because you know there were some
questions Nikki Haley's doing a great
job
Rex is doing a fantastic job our
Secretary of State a general McMaster
fantastic but if you add it all up and
if they take every little word they'll
say oh they're different just so you
understand we're not going into Syria
but when I see people using horrible
horrible chemical weapons which they
agreed not to use under the Obama
administration but they violated it okay
and in so again the point here is not
just to say that he flips on things
because a lot of politicians flip on
things the point here is to say that he
seems to be flipping in a more practical
direction on a lot of these things now
there areas where he's flipping in a non
practical direction so you've now said
that he's in favor of the export-import
bank which is just a corporatist
nonsense thing he's flipping on some of
his tax policies which I don't think
it's a good thing but when it comes to
foreign policy he's flipping into a much
more realistic position with regard to
Russia he realizes now that Russia's in
a variance force in the world he's
flipping into a more realistic position
on North Korea people are laughing at
this yesterday but I actually didn't see
what was so crazy about it he was
talking apparently with with the
presidents of China Xi Jinping and he
and he apparently said that um that that
ji had told him about
what was going on with North Korea and
he realized that it wasn't as simple as
just telling the Chinese to get rid of
kim jeong-hoon well people are laughing
at that like shouldn't have known that
already I should have known that already
but he learns the Machine learns right
that's a good thing the fact that he is
now realizing that new information is
changing his opinion that's a good thing
I don't think that that's a bad thing
the problem here is that he doesn't have
any study principles so normally what
you'd want from a president is somebody
who has a set a set of principles upon
which he can rely and then the
information that he's given changes how
he reacts based on those principles the
problem with Trump is he doesn't
actually have a steady base of
principles and so we don't actually know
what his principles are so when he gets
new information it doesn't just shift
his approach it shifts his entire
worldview his worldview is shifting day
by day five minutes ago it was horrible
to to bomb a sovereign country if they
were using gas on their own people now
it's imperative that we bomb a sovereign
country if they use gas on their own
people five minutes ago it was terrible
that NATO was was sucking up oxygen now
it's great that NATO is out there
fighting the Russians five minutes ago
Vladimir Putin was a wonderful guy we
were going to make a deal with and now
Blackmer Putin's nefarious force in the
world again it would've been better if
we had had all those positions up front
because then a lot of people wouldn't
feel cheated and I want to talk about
whether people who were Trump's biggest
supporters ought to feel cheated in just
a second but first I want to say thank
you to our friends over at tracker comso
as I have said before you know the
tracker comm is where you go TR ACK our
comm promo code Ben you get a free
tracker Bravo what the tracker does is
you attach it to your phone and attach
it to your keys you put in your wallet
and then you can use an app on your
phone to track down exactly where your
keys in your wallet are as I said before
this helps my marriage this is one of
the pet peeves that both my wife has me
and I have with her and that is we lose
stuff on an incredibly frequent basis
and the tracker has solved that problem
because now we both have the app on our
phone and if we lose our wallet or our
keys and we're trying to rush out the
door we just go to the app and we and we
set it up and then we search for our
phone and it immediately comes up and by
the way if you lose your phone itself
then you can have a setting on there
that you attach one of your keys the
setting on the phone will actually be
overridden so if your phone is on silent
this how often is this happened your
phone is on silent when you lose your
phone and now you're looking around and
you're trying to call it and doesn't
matter well what the tracker does is it
actually rings for to the phone and that
means that you are going to be able to
locate your phone even if you put it on
silent which is an awesome
awesome thing the tracker calm promo
code then it's only the coin size device
you can see it on your screen right here
and it'll save you tons of time and tons
of aggravation and it's the little
things that drive you crazy it isn't the
big things and let that make you
completely nutty it's the little things
like losing your keys in your wallet to
make you totally insane the tracker comm
prevents that to go to the tracker no II
the tracker calm and use that promo code
then you get a free tracker Bravo with
any purchase ok so what the the reason
that it's important to have principles
and not just flip your principles based
on the events of the day is you never
know if you don't know what the basic
principles are if you don't have a
generalized worldview you don't know
which piece of information is actually
going to hit home is it the piece of
information that putting American troops
on the ground is going to be damaging to
your popularity rating or is a piece of
information where you're watching TV and
they're a bunch of dead Syrian kids on
the TV which piece of information hits
home now if you have a worldview we can
basically predict as people how you're
going to react to a given piece of
information because the information will
go to confirm in worldview or or reject
your worldview but when you don't know
what exactly Trump is basing his
positions on it makes things really
difficult and this is what's happening
in the in fight inside the
administration between Steve Bannon and
Steven Miller and on the one side and
Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump on the
other at Trump as I said before is
running this administration like it's a
family business that's not a great shock
he runs the family business like a
family business now he's running the
White House like a family business Jared
Kushner who has all of the same
qualifications as my three-year-old
daughter to be in charge of China policy
is now in charge of China policy Middle
East policy heroin policy a he doesn't
have expertise on any of this but he's
loyal to Trump into Trump likes him on
the other hand you got Steven and Steven
and represents a nationalist populist
movement that thinks that that big
government is basically okay but we have
to protect our borders and we have to be
more isolationist on foreign policy and
sort of the nationalist populist
movement there's more crossover I think
between the nationalist populist
movement and conservative policy than
there is between Ivanka and Jared and
conservative policy because both of them
are career Democrats and so what you've
got right now is Steve Annan who is an
admittedly bad guy who does not actually
believe a lot of conservative things and
then you've got Jared and a bonk on the
other side who don't believe any
conservative things but
are nicer people and so there are no
good options for conservatives you're
sort of hoping that from bumbles his way
into just delegating power to all of the
people he's appointed like nikki Haley
is doing good job Rex Tillerson is doing
surprisingly - Jen I'm shocked at how
how Rex Tillerson has been hawkish on
Russia I did not expect to see that
coming
and and so all that's good Trump needs
to delegate all of that not to Jardin
Ivanka but to the people that he has
appointed to the positions who are
actually qualified for those positions
otherwise the more Trump medals the more
you just wonder what piece of
information is going to flip his mind
today because I don't think that what
we're seeing is a full growth of Trump
into the job I think what we're seeing
is that Trump is responding and reacting
that's what Trump does I don't think
he's changed his personality I just
think that he's reacting to events that
now impact him in a way they didn't do
the it's easy to say when you're a
candidate okay so somebody gasses a few
children it's different when everybody
in the world is saying you're the leader
of the free world what are you going to
do a bunch of children just got gassed
things changed pretty radically but it
does leave up in the air what if a new
piece of information emerges that flips
from back-right what happens if if he
decides that it's more important to make
a deal with the Russians and to speak
the truth about what Russia is doing so
for example Russia's Sergey Lavrov
yesterday he came out he said there's no
evidence that Assad used chemical
weapons you know as foolish foolish
chance that this investigation will go
reveals he BGE government identification
and chemical an agony regime Quebec
because he knew boohead sauce on the
caffeine age is hypothetical we do not
want to personally institutional comfort
in Calais and you're pretty mr. Sorvino
seeds how regulation dope-ass didn't
ever come they're saying that there's a
he's saying that we have no information
that it was necessarily Assad Assad is
saying the same thing he's saying that
he thinks it was the deep state that
helped plant this and they're the ones
who are attacking the United States and
Trump he's actually trying to avoid
Assad is trying to avoid pissing off
Trump here's what he actually said this
is just breaking right now he said I was
very cautious in saying any opinion
regarding him before he became president
and after I always say let's see what
he's going to do we wouldn't comment on
the statements so actually this is the
first proof that it's not about the
presidents in the United States it's
about the regime and the deep State or
the deep regime in the United States is
still the same it doesn't change the
president is only one of the perform
whirs on their theater if he wants to be
a leader he cannot because of some say
he wanted to be a leader Trump wanted to
be a leader but every president there if
he wants to be a real leader later he's
going to eat his word swallow his pride
and make a 180-degree u-turn otherwise
he would pay the price politically
that's Assad parroting messages that are
coming out of the Russian regime is that
going to impact Trump we don't know
because we don't know Trump's worldview
hopefully over time his worldview will
develop you know every president enters
office saying they're basically going to
be an isolationist very few end up that
way we will see what his world view
actually ends up being or whether it's
just defined by Jared Ivanka or Bannen
or whomever it's a lot of confusion
right now and Trump is not doing
anything to tamp down that confusion all
I can say is that a lot of the flips
he's making right now I think are good
in terms of policy but there are some
that are still bad he's a mixed bag he
will always be a mixed bag so long as he
doesn't have a worldview okay so now I'm
gonna have to go over to Daily wire to
check out the rest of the show we're
going to talk about the reactions from
the right and why there's so many who
are part of Trump's hardcore base who
are very upset about Syria because they
think the Trump had a worldview that he
obviously doesn't and so we'll talk
about what that means for Trump in the
future of his presidency you have to go
over to Daley wired.com and check that
out $8 a month over at Daley what we're
also going to be talking about the Sean
Spicer situation in the media going nuts
over Sean Spicer in the Holocaust $8 a
month that you get an annual
subscription today you get a free copy
of the Arroyo which is a terrific
fictional movie set on the border by our
very own Jeremy boring all about the
issues that plague the ranchers who live
on the border their land being used as a
thoroughfare for drugs and prostitution
and an illegal immigration and what one
rancher decides to do about it
go over and get the annual subscription
right now at daily wire.com and check in
agony also part of the mailbag which
we'll be doing tomorrow here at daily
wire.com you want all your questions
answered and all your life issues solved
we can make that happen for you over at
Daley wire.com you just want to listen
later go over to iTunes or SoundCloud
and check out the show and make sure if
you're listening at itunes to leave a
review we always appreciate it and we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you